we will make up time i hope
don't laugh clear
look it's great to be here and and on a
good day in southland it's always a good
day
um
uh i can sort of check we are live
streaming now brilliant
so
so uh welcome to those uh either in the
public gallery or to those that are also
joining in by way of live streaming
welcome to our meeting
um
getting close to uh key time in the year
for us all
particularly as we try and move and wrap
up towards annual reporting although
that's got some way to go and there's
more on that
we have the agenda in front of us and
i'd just like to start with it
appropriately which is firstly to record
are there any apologies i received one
this morning from alex
um and in a reflection to reflect her
problem i think as a as a young mum she
finds these starts early and she has
said to me bruce i hope you might fix
that but it's not my call
the council might fix that in terms of
the the new geronium in terms of uh
timing but i'll i'll pass on what it's
worth we have alex's apology
and i have to pop away for half an hour
at a bus line and you have to pop sorry
yet about nine how about nine thank you
i thought you said how past one and i
thought perhaps i should be trying to
finish before i passed one in revere
cause so that's fine are there any other
apologies that we need to sustain
there being none i'll put the motion
that we sustain those apologies so i
have a second to please
thank you uh uh rangi all those in favor
please say aye aye all right those
against
it's kerry thank you
uh declarations of interest any matters
in front of us in terms of business that
we need to
raise or declare matters of interest
i'd like to raise that i do um and i'd
like to give this a more expansion on
that when we get to px
um but there is uh item seven uh in the
uh the px
part of our agenda
for which there's a risk that i could be
perceived
to have a position of bias so i've
arranged
with ross that when we deal with that
that i ask ross to take the chair as i
leave the chamber for that item but i
can explain more when we get to px thank
you very much
right
i haven't been informed of anybody
wishing from the public to speak at this
stage
so if we could turn our uh look to the
agenda
it's in front of you i at this stage
haven't been informed of urgent business
um and obviously we have the public
excluded sessions so at this stage i
propose that we
truck on through a normal fashion
through the agenda
as it is set down
right could we move to the first item
please which is the minutes for the last
meeting
on the 12th
of june
i would like to move from the chair
that we accept these minutes
as uh
confirmed the train correct record do i
have a second to please thank you nobby
there's any discussion matters of
correction
um uh or the likes that we should uh
record at the stage
look pretty good to me and i think if
there's any action points they do they
do um they do come up in the rest of the
agenda so from this position i'll move
that motion second by nobody thank you
all those in favor please say aye
those against
carrie thank you very much
right working on working together
um uh we're risk update report michael
welcome to the welcome to the table good
to see you sir
very keen to hear your thoughts
what anna everybody
i think is the first
update post the
end of the working on working together
official program
however has noted there are a number of
risks that remained live
so this is the first report to cover
those off there are four risks uh
detailed in the body of the report
um
most of those do come to an end
with the coming of the elections however
the appendix however sets out
a number of ongoing projects that we
have as a consequence of this program
and just provides a simple
update on where all of those are at and
that they are still in the thoughts of
staff as we progress
um so with the interest of a full agenda
i will leave it there and happy to
answer any questions
thank you for helping me with my agenda
mark that's superb do you have questions
for michael's stage please
yes uh councillor pottinger
um
look looking at the um table there i see
i see one thing there which table please
uh the future reporting against outcomes
yes that's page four three four five six
of the agenda
yeah it just talks like twenty sorry
yeah it just talks about um you know uh
governance and
induction and training and everything
one thing that has been brought up over
the last
while is the effectiveness
usefulness and relevance
of our code of conduct
now
obviously you can understand why the
code of conduct's there but
it's it's sort of
transpired
the dia's view on this and this is my
take on it is that the use of the code
of conduct is actually
sort of taboo and you're going down you
know that's that's not very nice even
though you can see why it's there for a
reason you know you look at all the
different aspects of it so i'm just
wondering where
we sit in that moving forward because we
either have it and use it
or we get rid of it
because it seems to get us into trouble
yeah so a code of conduct is a required
document you must have one
and you can generally most councils will
set it at the start of the
training term
and that will be the code of conduct set
in stone that being said i'm also aware
that environment southland i saw in the
media today are reviewing their code of
conduct
so it is in process at the moment we are
reviewing it so that we can take a new
code of conduct through to
the incoming council
uh there will be some proposed changes
my team have been looking at a number of
different critical conducts from
different councils
and it's been quite interesting the
differences in the different mechanisms
that can be used rather than the
relatively blunted instrument that ours
currently is so it is in progress as
part of the induction work
just doing a bit of online reading last
night i see that hut city actually
imposed a monetary
fine on one of their members using the
code of conduct now that they were
completely outside it
but this is the type of thing i'm just
wondering it it goes further is this
something that
that local government or central
government are looking at because
or is it just up to each council to
realize
so it is up to each council but i am
also aware that lgnz has done some work
on codes of conduct for local
authorities
and the minister has politely asked them
to hold off on any further work until
such time as the future for local
government has been
um that report has been presented so it
is something that
both the minister
and lgnz are aware of and that there are
some deficiencies in
the code of conduct process
but at the moment as it is up to each
council and how they adopt it and
basically how big a stick they want
their code of conduct to wield
okay thanks thank you
ian darren i think you're next um
in the nobby
thanks cheer um
i think we've been using a template
from lgnz in in recent years
and it's reassuring to know that it is
being looked at because in some senses
accountability is is left wanting but
i think to pick up on the point that
councillor pottinger made about the dia
their concern was not the
uh the code of conduct itself but more
often in our case how often it was being
used and i guess while it's there as a
tool that's available
the point that they made through the
working on working together process was
to
um
make sure it wasn't overused
thank you darren nobby yeah
it's my understanding there's a local
government commission that's looking
into this
um
i've had some input into that i guess
other councils may have as well they're
looking at the relevance of codes of
conduct
how they are investigated because from
their perspective there was a lack of
consistency each council just sort of
identifies somebody that might do it
the cost involved
and also the issue of our codes of
conduct being used to
put pressure on
um i guess councils is a little bit out
of line and so i i don't know when that
where that report's gone to
but i assume it would go back to dia
back to the minister but it was part of
an overall look at local government
and it's it's and it's independent as
well thanks snobby that the the local
government commission report is
available on their website yep
um and it does is you're ironic give
rise to a substantial substantial
overhaul sure um i've always uh for what
what's worth i hate to say it but i do a
number of them if i could just add a
weaver to to the question you raised the
in one is one is
it was always accepted when we first
reviewed these the order off sort
the value is a bit like the work you've
done on your good work you've been on
your charter it's actually agreeing up
front what are the values that you
mutually want to subscribe to
as a chamber
and as members of that chamber
that's the critical part it's often
overlooked by the way when you come to
induction michael there's a bit of
advice spend a bit of time more than the
normal 90 seconds
the challenging part is is actually the
investigation
and that is that is uh the the local
government new zealand template from a
personal perspective has its challenges
to the point that
we are exactly where you see where it
needs to be done i want to reflect
uh on two things the the the fourth risk
that is still there is complacency
um uh and i wanted to make a comment on
that one without michael which is right
it's in the risk register
but actually i think that's the biggest
challenge for us is that we feel we have
got through working on working together
and yet we forget
the good work that was done
to look at the behavior that should
occur inside the chamber and how we make
good useful decisions for our community
and the code is part of that by the way
and but i think we have and all wanted
to subscribe to the higher core which is
the charter
and i would just want to reflect on that
so
um you're quite right codes are still
there as far as i know they'll still be
part of the induction work that you you
know you'll have to do when it comes to
uh post late october um
and darren you're right only if you're
pulling it down
actually it's too late if you pull it
off the shelf to use it it's too late
that something else should have happened
prior
that's the best advice i could give you
any other questions for michael in terms
of in terms of
the paper
what if i could just check a couple of
things again i'm thinking putting this
back to the table
and i just was wanting to check two
things you've answered the first one
which is induction clearly is big on the
mind of the council you're thinking
through the processes that sit behind
working on working together which is
really superb
um i'm just wanting to know a wee bit
around some of the monitoring that that
is to occur has occurred or will occur
under this framework and there's one
that's due i think for reporting in
september next month
i will give an indication that that
presumably must be in train now
so if i'm looking at it
it is it is where are we for instance on
page 20
under
the top of the page is a quarterly
internal quality assurance check first
report due in 30 september 22.
and it used to occurs a number of
that that's in hand is it yes brilliant
okay that's what i wanted to hear
right
are there any other questions then for
michael that that
that people would like to raise there
aren't
can we move to the to the
recommendations please which is that we
receive the report do i have a move in a
second to please thank you darren
thank you rebecca appreciate that i'll
put the motion or is there any
discussion on the motion
there being none i'll put it all those
in favor please say aye all right those
against
it's carrie thank you
roddy
thank you for that michael i suspect
we'll get you back later so i appreciate
your presence this morning
right the performance report for the
fourth quarter and they're only four
quarters of the year so we are getting
close to balance time
um and it's a good chance for us to
reflect uh with all without elections
coming up brandon welcome to the meeting
very keen to hear what you'd like to
point out for us please
um
so obviously this is the fourth quarter
performance report that i still um there
is still some work on going before the
annual report provides the final picture
but i think this provides a a good
picture of where we're at in terms of
of the previous year um
so this report
provides you with the report that went
to the performance policy and
partnerships committee while drawing out
a few points of note for this committee
um
so i think the first thing that i'll
just note is that while um
council delivered 68 of the capital
program it was the largest capital
program ever delivered by this council
and that is a big achievement
this report also outlines some of the
work that is ongoing and was reported
to this last committee meeting around
the performance framework improvements
so that work is ongoing and on schedule
and that will enable um
management to keep a more regular kind
of update and overview of all aspects of
performance and build towards
the next ltp and further aligning the
kpis and the way they are measured to
get
them as useful as possible we have
implemented continuous surveying now for
the resident survey so that will mean
that
council will get regular results for
that through the year
then in terms of service performance
areas of focus have just identified
three that will be the key focuses for
the teams
over the next year the first of those is
waste net and their focus on the waste
minimization plan the second is building
on
the upward trend that we were seeing in
the fourth quarter um in terms of usage
of public facing facilities so while the
results as an overall don't look good i
think when you look at the fourth
quarter results you can really see that
the connect the city coming out of that
restriction period
and then
the third notes that it has been a very
sad year for
road traffic accidents within the city
and that's really affected the roading
kpis um
council did implement the new speed
limit review so that will come into
come into force in various periods over
the next year and should have an impact
and then in terms of the financial
performance areas of focus obviously
there was an impact on the budget in
terms of when subsidies came through
which was much discussed as the annual
plan was undertaken there'll be a
continued focus in 2223 around revenue
from fees and charges which is still a
little bit below where we would want it
to be in terms of balancing up the types
of revenue they're coming into council
infrastructure and the
project management office are going to
keep building on their good progress in
terms of the capital program and we're
going to look as i said in terms of how
we can better use information to help
all the teams across council in their
day-to-day delivery
thank you anne look um i'm conscious
that you quite rightly pointed it's gone
to ppp so darren i just wonder whether
there's any comments from the ppp
discussion bearing our role is risk
insurance rather than rather than your
policy work is there anything from ppp
you'd like to say about the report at
the stage before i know we just noted
that um whilst it is the final quarter
there are still figures that are being
compiled for the annual report so yes
yeah yeah still always always happens
that way they can some regions can't be
done until post based balance state i
get that yes
right are there questions folk would
like to raise your sin
um look
i must comment on the waste net we'll be
focusing on the implementation of the
wmmp now there's quite a few things
that make this a complete misstatement
um
wastenet hasn't met since june 2020
so that is a risk in itself to have a
joint committee with so much
responsibility
that's going to uh sort of a hiatus or
it's it's just gone i don't know what's
happened to and then the waste
minimization plan
that was supposedly created in june 2020
um is non-compliant with
the waste minimization act because of
its failure to consult
under its guidelines now the
implementation of this act if you read
the ford written by waste nets
chairperson
in the new plan
supposedly new plan it states that
there's going to be a two-year holding
pattern
now if you get a plan that says there's
a two-year holden holding pattern that's
quite easy to implement isn't that you
do nothing
so
how can an organization that hasn't met
for two years
implement something
that isn't compliant
and really has no substance to it i'm
sorry but i'm pleased it's arrived at
this committee because it is a huge risk
uh as we found out in our annual plan
our
waste kilos per capita has risen from
650 which we're trying to reduce i mean
it's called a minimization plan we seem
to be operating under a maximization
plan
and we were given in the annual plan
report
um
reasons that weren't that
they weren't held together by
a lot of accurate data
about an increase of people making more
waste
but surely over a two year period
we should be on to this and yet
this statement here i find completely
completely wrong
and has it shouldn't be here because
waste net will not be doing anything
yes snobby
just to reinforce that as well um i'm
wondering whether
we should be doing this as a local
authority ourselves and not not um
wanting waste net to do it because as
rangy quite rightly says they haven't
met for the best part of 18 months or
two years
um the contract we have with the
recycling
agency is
driven by the city even though one of
the other councils does
have a supplementary contract with us
not not the provider
and i just think the mechanism of using
waste net will not get us where we need
to be
it's long overdue and i think we should
as a city just get on and do our own
plan and if others then want to adopt it
or align with it that's fine
but just to sit in a system that's
clearly not working it's not a way
forward on what is a very important
issue now i accept that the um
the government beyond waste net is a
moving feast from one month to the next
you i mean you get this rush of blood
and we're going to have recycling of
glass bottles but then there's a hiatus
and you hear nothing forever while they
troll it somewhere so um that's one
issue
and the other issue for me is um
more a structural thing i noticed in one
of the papers that we're going to deal
with as we go forward in today's agenda
there is
a frame time framework for
early in the next trienium for
the new council to discuss the i guess
the scope or focus of the risk assurance
committee and i guess just an
observation for me depending on whether
i'm here or not here at the end of end
of october is that i see the amount of
work coming into this committee to be
very extensive it's grown over time
and i wonder whether we need to um
to reflect like like this report
fragmented's already been to ppp
and i think in an ideal world its next
port of call would have been full
council just to adopt but it seems that
we we go to pvp we come out here because
you could argue everything we do in
council has a risk at one level
um and then it goes on to full council
like it's three bites of the cherry in
some ways and i just wonder that
it would be helpful to have some work
before we get to that scoping exercise
in the next training
to have some benchmarking of what really
needs to come to this this
this committee and what could
an and a risk model
be going somewhere else
it's nothing sort of like yep and i i
appreciate that
so a couple of questions being raised
i don't know whether you or one of your
colleagues could help you um uh so
i guess the question that i've heard
from ian is actually so what what how do
we how does this get acted on we've
identified
we've identified a a um
a need and i and i think right again if
i could say it properly um
uh you're saying there's a need because
waste needs not meeting and the waste
management minimisation plan has its
challenges
i think that's probably inappropriate
around and says well we've got to focus
on this for next year i wonder if
there's anything you could add that
would that would help us understand more
some of the challenges yeah thank you
through your chair um
the waste advisory group did me earlier
this year back in april and they
discussed a number of factors which we
need to take into account as a council
we are currently looking at the waste
minimisation management plan itself and
we have engaged with the ministry for
the environment
on the procedure matters that the
council has raised and we will be
bringing back a report to the
infrastructure services committee
on their
assessment of our process back in 2020.
thank you
so obviously more to work on there and i
hope that that is i mean it's an
indicative of a process that's not
necessarily the answer you're after but
at least there's a process in place to
actually deal with what you've
characterized as as a risk which i think
is important well i don't
what i see is a massive failure a
failure
and this committee is about dealing with
failures
and it's a failure that i don't believe
should have occurred because
you've got an act that guides you
through all the processes
so it shows that
the joint committee is it the problem of
having a joint committee no one takes
responsibility
and
and these are the things that happen
because of that
it's a critical thing it's impacted on
us by over 800 000 at the last annual
plan and put a rates rise up we did not
know about this until the last minute
that these figures had been suddenly
escalated
so
yeah to me
we're going to do something really
doesn't cut the mustard because
there is no evidence i don't see
anything
that
points me as especially as chairman of
infrastructure that anything will happen
sorry
i'm not convinced i'm not convinced as
chairman i haven't been involved
i believe that i thought this would have
come at a level where i may have been
involved but i haven't
and i've sat back and watched this
unfold they're very frustrating
well i think all we can do is note your
frustrations here i'm got good advice
here about a process to follow forward i
suspect there's chair of infrastructure
that will be something that you will be
currently encouraging
sorry current chairman a couple of
months ago yeah don't worry uh i i um i
hear that point so um i think
uh
your your concerns have been expressed
and i think it isn't irrelevant sorry i
think it is relevant to raise them here
in terms of risk have we got a challenge
here and think around for raising it i
get that
appreciate that uh nobby you also raised
the issue of the scope of this committee
and i think that's always good at the
end of each training to reflect on the
scope of the committee so i would
absolutely endorse your comments as far
as that's concerned
there are other comments people would
like to raise for random's report
i've got a couple questions randomly
that's okay please um uh which is useful
um i was very grateful to get the
expanded sense of what you're doing in
terms of the improvement process around
it and look i just want to encourage you
guys as you do that that's great to hear
that there's a level of of recognition
about the need to
continuously improve in terms of in
terms of our reporting you just give me
any sense about the new methodology
though that you've introduced for
satisfaction kpis and i raise that
because it's for me it's also related to
our working on working together
initiative where you'll recall when we
concluded that
we know that internally
processes have improved we've got the
right sort of culture
there are problems with the rest of the
community catching up with us so i'm
interested in how how the new
methodology may or may not help us with
that
so um the main shift is
twofold so it's around when we're
surveying and how we're surveying so
previously there's been a survey
once a triennium in support of the
long-term plan development which looked
at levels of service of what the
community wanted in terms of levels of
service
so now we are introducing satisfaction
kpis and measuring them more frequently
that
is now happening basically continuously
but reported quarterly and then they
will build to a statistically sound
sample by the end of the year so there
will be some ups and downs as we go
through the year and we have moved from
a primarily telephone based survey to
primarily online survey so it's not
wholly online that is supported by
street surveying and
phone surveying to fill gaps so you
still come up with a statistically sound
sample but
it is a normal found
kind of process that when you move from
a primarily phone based survey to an
online one satisfaction levels if you're
monitoring kpis across those things they
dip because people
are
more negative when they're not speaking
to an actual human being so that is
something that needs to be taken into
account in terms of these results and i
think also um
just being aware that obviously the
types of
thoughts that people have when
responding to a survey very much depends
on what they're experiencing at that
time which is another reason we've moved
to continuous to try to remove blips
around things as simple as weather and
just what is in the media at one point
in time but there is no perfect
methodology yeah so you're balancing up
your balancing up frequency and ability
to to remove the um geo as i didn't get
enough sleep last night sort of type
thing along with the fact that online
people can tend to tend to i presume
that scientifically proved be more
negative
so
i hear your point so uh but equally i
think it probably makes sense so that's
you thank you for that
um i did have one question and i asked
this
in conscious that we already talked
about what goes to other committees
uh on page 28
um it says the uh so this was recognized
in the 70s 70 achievement um
don't know whether 70 out of 100 is good
or bad i think it's good i think
particularly when you start to look at
the quantum of capital
delivered as in contrast to where we've
been in the past that's appeared
the last thing that says the three
waters pipe capital renewal programs
were each under spent for the year due
to contractor availability
and will be managed within future con
the future continuous program i get the
general just gist of that i want to ask
a question is this a red
flag um of of what we perceive as
potential ongoing difficulty in our in
in finishing our renewal program or is
it something that we you know it's
crystal ball gazing that that that might
just be a blip at the moment i'm again
looking down the line that may not be
your question rihannon but i just wonder
if i could
erase that as i say is this something
that we should be concerned about or do
we see this as being been a matter
that is that is similar
thank you through you mr chair um look
our team are very mindful of the
planning and the delivery on the current
conditions in the market and are
certainly engaging with the contractors
through
the range of agreements we have
they are building in a slightly bigger
program to
to foreshadow
any supply chain issues or any other
market-driven issues which mean that
they can't deliver as per program so
we're confident this number will grow
in terms of performance against target
budget in the coming year
and they are mitigating as much as they
can within their powers to make sure
we're delivering on the targets
um
michael do you want to add anything
thank you um
given we're doing a joint role in
relation to covering off the
infrastructure there's a mix in relation
to the renewals programs just at the
moment what i'd like to highlight to the
committee is we've actually got more
contracts engaged in relation to our
renewals program at this time of the
year than any other year
that we've had so
we're we've
learned from the past and we've actually
been addressing as we've moved forward
in the last year so we've now got to a
place where we've got earlier contract
involvement and we're ready we're into
the market early in the financial year
so we we're
more confident of the delivery over the
course of this year than we have been in
others great okay so that's an
improvement so i won't i won't take that
as a flag but it's something
uh stephen and michael that actually you
know from if there's a valid role for us
to be dipping our toes into into the
water it's actually pun intended um uh
it's the sort of stuff that we are
maintaining things like our maintenance
programs which are they fall over
they come back and bite you later in
future generations not necessarily next
year navi just a couple of reflections
on that um
it doesn't bode well for the new water
entities that are coming in two years
from now that we can't get work done
because of contractor availability
that's one of the real flags that we've
floated with the dia and just seems to
fall on deaf ears
the other observation i've got is more
of a generic one around what other
councils are doing
some are just doing business as usual
and that's my
my view of what we're doing here we're
trying to do what we would normally do
regardless of three waters
or the three waters reform some other
ones are reducing and saying well why
would i put the money in now let the
entity put it in at a later stage and
there's a risk as we've heard of if
contract is not available they may miss
out on investment in the short to medium
term
other councils and some close to here
are pouring money into the three waters
area on the assumption that whatever
debt they're
drawing up now will be taken over by the
entity but of course the top politics of
that is if the
government changes and there's a wine
back on three waters they're left with a
huge debt
even though they do have improved
infrastructure
so it seems as though we're doing we're
doing the right thing dia have said that
they are watching
for those ebbs and flows to make sure
that people aren't going to either end
of the spectrum
yes there's certainly uncertain times in
that sense so uh um i hear your point
about endorsement that we carry on with
normal work that's why i raised my
questions about how's the renewal
program yes michael sorry
could i ask i just you want to talk to
respond to that because i've got leslie
with a question as well yes i'll go for
it
through yourself chair just want to
highlight the
council's concern in relation to the
renewals program on funding side of it
and highlight the borrowing side a
renewals program is rates funding but
there is an opportunity with the three
waters if we could accelerate the
program
um to change that to borrowing which i
know other councils have sought
and if we had the suppliers available
that is something we could bring to the
infrastructure committee at a later date
thank you uh yes
just in relation to michael's michael's
response here i think that's an
avenue or an opportunity for us
one of the things that continues to
worries me is our alternative water
supply
um i know we're doing work in that area
but it is still a very big risk for the
city there our only supply of water is
the riku river if that was compromised
we're in big big trouble
so
advancing that to me it has to be a
priority um it worries me that once we
get into the new entity it will not be a
high priority for
for the new entity it has pressures
elsewhere
i appreciate there's a level of strategy
here which is which is useful is
prompted i'm glad to say from a good
questions come out of the risk committee
michael so it is something that we
should follow through on um i think we
it's clear on that and um i actually
hear from you that we are following
through on which is also comforting
leslie thank you for your patience
thank you mr chair um also page 28 has
it happens all right
just the comment there that the anderson
house
project has been completed in july 2022
due to some current um or some recent
media comment i just wondered if we
could ask mr giblin
to expand on what has been completed
and what we are now waiting on
through the chair um
richard here leslie um anson house the
capital project has uh come to a
completion there's just a few minor
defects to work through but that it's
the capital aspect that is completed the
next phase is
uh opening up to the public via the
trust and the negotiations with the uh
agreement with the trust and also the
leasing arrangement that we'll have so
that's the next steps
thanks very much richard
thank you
i had a couple of observations michael
around finance but we get to that later
on when we get to the treasury
management report so that's i'll leave
that for that are there any other
questions folk would like to raise with
the symbol team
there being none i wonder if we could
just move to the
resolutions please which is uh
um that we received the report uh we
note the report
um uh to the ppp
um and
uh the fourth quarter including the
fourth quarter
uh performance report and we note the
progress on the approach to continuous
improvement of the performance
management and reporting as as rhiannon
has discussed with us this morning
i'll move that from the chat i have a
second to please
thank you rebecca i appreciate that
there's any discussion on the motion
being done i'll put all those in favor
please say hi
those against it's gary thank you ryan
appreciate that
right
good move to
confirmation of the internal audit plan
peter welcome
good morning mr chairman councillors
just like to make some comments on the
um appendix a while it's a heavy focus
on
food regulations and building
regulations this is to keep us on track
to retain our accreditation in those
areas
each year we do receive a number of
requests from teams across council for
additional reviews and audits an example
would be we're just completing a
audit of our rates rebate process to
ensure we're following the process and
ensure that those entitlement actually
get the rebate
additionally we've just completed a
review of our governance reports and the
process
for those to try and improve the
timeliness of the reports coming through
so that we can actually monitor what
stage they are at
so there is additional reports apart
from those that are in this report here
thank you better appreciate that that's
a very good context though i was
interested in um i was interested in
uh as you say a regulation heavy
internal appendix a which um
uh is is good
we've also got the broader internal
audit stuff i wonder if michael there's
any comment you want to make or on on
the other table
which is the proposed internal order
program through the voice
yes through yourself chair um just like
to highlight we do have a procurement
review but
scheduled for 23 24 and i'll talk to
that there's an item in
pe item six where i'll talk about where
we've got to in relation to our
procurement processes etc and while that
and the reason behind that scheduling in
23 24 fits in with our timeline in
relation to that so i just want to
highlight that one
so i think this is a we hit it
uh
i think this is a an important little
important point we're going to dwelt
along it as a committee but important
for the committee just to reflect this
is our chance to influence
making certain that we you know we we
look an analogy we have a clean nose
this is our chance this is our chance to
to look and see
getting staff peter's team or indeed
deloitte spend a few bit of money with
to focus on things that really count
that we need to know and have the
assurance management have control over
and obviously peter at some stage jack
we get a summary of your reports coming
back which is really important so it's
quite critical that we we look at this
we talk about risk on one side but our
role is risk and assurance this is a big
part of our assurance along with our
friends from external audits so
so um are there any other comments
people would like to raise
you're snobby
two issues um
in the in the original uh
recommendations it talks about
adopting the the proposed deloitte's
review and table one i i can't see that
anyway
so you can't see well i can't see any
deloitte uh
report on page 93 of your agenda
in diligence belgium books or war books
what do we call it
well that's just our proposed
are you saying that the
review at the top is
yes yes that's the that's the proposed
program that we would that we would ask
deloitte to do over the coming three
years
the other issue is the issue of the
procurement review
which is one of the last reviews to be
done in year 2324 and given what we
haven't
report coming forward in
in pe today
just wonder whether that's
an area that we might want to reconsider
good call
michael
yes through yourself chair
just want to step counsel through why
why while the timing is um late what
what leads into that and why uh we're
looking at 2324
that's i'm happy to step us through that
to explain why that's there and not
brought forward any earlier
we've uh history of this as we had
procurement guidelines in place
in um
prior to about two years ago and we
decided that we wanted to put a full
policy into a full procurement policy
review
we've only recently had that policy in
place for just over
nine to ten months
that new policy that now in place we are
trying to educate and train the
organization in the new ways that is a
big culture shift from an organizational
point of view
and
we're we're at a stage where we want to
actually move that to
a compliance checking ourselves so at
the moment
the resourcing that i have available in
the space
is to
focus in on the big and large tendering
documents and
and support those we don't have the
ability within the team at this stage to
actually get into the lower uh level and
that bracket is around the 250 bracket
so we're focused on trying to get
compliance requirements at the contracts
above that initially
i would like to have a compliance regime
in place and we're working through that
at the moment how we could achieve that
it is resource constrained in relation
to that
what i would like to do is have that
compliance work and our regime in place
so we can give the
committee confidence in the council
confidence that we have got our
compliance the culture shift and we are
we can hold our heads up that we've got
the
regulations in place and the policies in
place that will meet the needs of this
organization
to do one while we haven't got any of
our compliance reporting in place means
that they're not doing a review of how
we're doing the process they're doing a
complete review that would be money not
well spent because we already know what
we need to improve on
as i mentioned before the only
constraint on doing it faster is the
fact that we are resource
constrained in relation to that it would
be we've got one resource focus on our
contract side of it at the moment and
they're heavily focused on getting our
tendering uh documents in relation to
large contracts in place
so just to interpret 250 by the way
under 150 000. it's 250 000 and above
yeah so 250 thousand dollars and above
you're confident that the process or
you're developing
from a compliance perspective from a
perspective of of
covering good practice
um we
that's where you're focused at the
moment but you're acknowledging that
with uh
uh i think you say resource constraint
it says to me like a lack of resource um
you're constrained to the level of work
you can do it at this stage in contracts
that are under 250 thousand dollars
great i suspect we may come back to that
when we look at item six in the in the
px agenda but there you go thank you for
that that contextual
advice yes
um just following on along this
topic
[Music]
procurement.grbt.nz
they outline
[Music]
sort of mandated
guidelines and the recommended
guidelines and also if you go to oag
they've done reports 2008 2009.
um this information is that a a useful
tool that you can fall back to as uh
as something i mean i've read all
through it and it's quite comprehensive
and it's sort of like a step-by-step you
know before you do each action
it's sort of like a just a simple
checklist
um is that useful or do we abide by that
or as is
is that something's and the other
question i've got is is our delegation
register still
the 2020 delegation register is that
still an action
through yourself chair i'll address the
first uh last one first because it's the
easiest one yes the delegation register
isn't in place and as in practice
the other one which is the
use of those procurement those
guidelines were the guidelines that we
were
using
prior to putting in the our own council
policy it would be fair to say our
council policy goes into more detail and
we have a framework that's attached to
that it's the framework that we need to
roll out and make sure people are now
following and adhering to the new
framework so we've gone further than
watson yeah that became as as we've
discussed with council in previous
sessions
that the new policy is a step step
further than what's on those guidelines
thank you any other questions at this
stage
uh rangi sorry no just one thought from
me which is i
said it wrong this is a three year
forward rolling program for the internal
order that table it's not it's actually
really there in effect now given where
at the end of 21 22. it's effectively
the next two years so
we're 12 months out from the procurement
review it's anticipated so there's a
target there for
um uh michael and the team to fill the
gaps so that we can actually
be
an external confirmation detroit okay
the other points people like to raise
being none of like to move to the
recommendations which is that we receive
the report we receive and endorse the
draft internal plan so that's both the
internal audit one for deloitte and it's
also peter's uh extensive and detailed
appendix a uh which is great to see
um oh sorry i've actually covered those
off haven't i sorry two and three we're
endorsing both of those do i have a
mover and a second for this police thank
you ross to have a second i thank you
ian was that your hand up yeah i think
it was thank you
any discussion on the motions being done
i'll put it all those in favor please
say aye
those against carried thank you very
much thank you peter appreciate that
thank you michael for your uh your input
right financial risks
good morning patricia welcome
morning everyone
in your hands patricia
okay i'll step through this because
there's a lot of information in the
treasury report report for this quarter
um
we have found that the markets are
continuing to move this was written so
the treasury report attached was written
at 30 june
it's continued to move um we are seeing
interest rates increase again
with the central bank increasing the
cash rate again
which
were um
is causing will cause some pressure
going forward
um we continue to have the policy breach
if we get to 150 million of borrowing in
25 26 it's a technical breach at this
point
we are closely looking at it and the
next lot of borrowing we do have quite a
bit of borrowing coming up for renewal
in october
so we will look to whether we can fix
that at that point in time
the market changes have resulted in an
average interest rate going higher than
what it was previously we've had one of
the lowest average interest borrowing
rates in the country from any council
that has gone up and we will have to
review our assumptions for the 2324
annual plan
that's very clear at this point
the other point that i want to mode is
we've um provided a brief summary on the
loan that we've provided to icl
the development loan
that including the balance at year end
it was at what we had lent 12.8 million
that's currently up to as of last week
15.15 million
but we are earning a commercial interest
rate
on that investment
in relation to
our rates our other debt that is being
managed very closely
and we do always expect to see a
um slight upturn at 30 june as all the
invoicing gets done
um but and the rates is the same the
significant increase at august is
because all the unpaid rates from the la
from the 21 22 year has become arrest so
that's 1.7 million
but we have seen that come down already
so as people have received their
installment notices for the first
installment they've realized that
there's an arrest amount
and we're seeing that come down or we're
getting payment plans put in place
um from that
all the points that i had that i wanted
to cover on any questions from yourself
thanks patricia appreciate that again i
suspect um i should offer you darren
chance because i think this has probably
come through your committee correct is
there anything that you want to raise at
the stage
nothing at the moment okay is there
questions that folk would like to raise
yes snobby
just more of
of a reflection really um patricia's
raised
this issue before about the 150 million
limit or the cap that we've imposed
internally
i just wonder whether as a council we
need to review that because that was set
at a time when the
uh ceiling for um
local government funding agency was
twice your income so we had us we had a
potential then to borrow up to 200 000
200 million
and a few years ago we set that limit at
the three-quarter level which is 150.
of course the limits now are three times
your
income which is about 350 by my
assessment which is significantly up and
i wonder whether that limit that we've
got should which is an internal limit
should be reviewed and pushed upwards
which would ease the pressure that the
finest people are always trying to keep
within it
and that doesn't mean that we just go
out and recklessly borrow another 50 or
100 million i'm not suggesting that but
it would take the pressure off what
appears to many to be a limit that we
can't bypass all that we constantly need
to report on
patricia michael would you have any
comments you can make at the stage about
the review of the the the selling that
the 150 million i just want to clarify
something from councillor clark 150
million isn't actually the debt ceiling
that's where we think in 2526 our
borrowing will be at
though policy limits are set as a
percentage of their expected borrowing
going forward
so um this borrowing also
um assumes that we have got three waters
in there as well so we need do need to
do a lot of work in relation to what the
borrowing may look like post the three
waters
yes okay
just as a reflection of that um people
that do
um troll over our reports and we do have
some externally um they keep seeing this
there's concern that we're going to
breach the 150 limit
so that we're being a little bit
reckless in some ways or getting ahead
of ourselves and not that's not the case
we're a very conservative council and
our net debtors
is probably better than most councils
certainly the majority uh i just wonder
whether we should do a little one-off
exercises to to
gaze at whether that's still an
appropriate level it's only set
internally it's not an external
limit
but that's okay
thank you for that and thank you for
that advice about about potentially
public perception about our deep
position um
uh it you know take your point nobody
and it's clear from the bank report that
we are uh i don't know whether it's
conservative but we are in a good
position with one of the
currently last rates um but i think you
will have signaled and we all you know
it would be difficult not to to
recognize that rate will go up in a good
question
yes regarding um
the comments around the the upcoming
annual plan uh the impact on interest
rates and then
more
i guess at a high level the long-term
plan and the projects
happening there so obviously when are we
how soon will we know
how off skew
are we going to be with our long-term
plan with this obviously
4.26
come 20 june 2027
and
when
because obviously
do we carry on blindly towards the cliff
and just say that's part of life
interest rates or
do we say we have the ability now to
shape our own destiny by perhaps looking
at certain projects that
may seem
a bit futile like streetscape stage two
it's not the end of the world
um and that allows us to carry on with
the more significant projects like the
museum and
and the breaks home and stuff like that
when are we gonna
know or sit down and actually punch in
the numbers
that'll
rather than obviously the last annual
plan we suddenly arrive
and go boom seven point something
percent that ended up down at six point
eight
and we missed the four percent by mile
currently we're looking at a four
percent at this current
next rates increase at four
and so on and so on and so on and then
the last three years dropped down to
three
when are we gonna
i guess it the early knowledge is
important to me that we're either yeah
now she's all good or we've got some
issues coming and doing it in the month
of june to me doesn't
doesn't feel right
yes
uh through yourself chair i'll ask two
of my colleagues to give you an
indication of timeline etc uh one being
patricia about the finance and also
economics i'll get um random to give you
some insight
just before they do low i would also uh
highlight there's
a lot of uncertainty in relation to what
we're doing and for the three waters and
what the financing of that is and what
the impact on our debt will be
there could be some choices for this
council to make is that three water
three waters
bill comes through in relation to how we
manage our finances that will have a
significant impact in the annual plan in
relation to what our forward debt
projections are going to be
uh having said that i will pass on to
in the first instance because it's
timeline i'll pass on to rhiannon if she
can
give you about timeline
indication um so in terms of the annual
plan and the long-term plan timeline and
assumptions we are very conscious
of the volatility
um in the environment at the moment
in terms of inflation and interest rates
but also
population with the impacts that the
close borders have had
so you'll recall at the last risk
insurance meeting the report that we had
commissioned by infometrics so we will
be getting an update of that and
council will get an update on that in
november
as we work on planning towards the
annual plan and the long-term plan and
we have begun scheduling when those
discussions around key projects will
happen within that context so that you
will get
the information that you need to make
the decisions for both the annual plan
and the long-term plan
i guess my worry is that in this pre
past just recent lot annual plan
we had
like we set the ltp and first year into
it
we blow the interest rates by
70 percent
we're we're at 6.8 we tell the public
for
we've told the public it's going to be
for this coming
rates increase
and yet out of the blue
last annual plan we had the solid waste
increases we had
uh wage parity living wage increases all
sorts of stuff that just appeared
at the last minute and and and uh here
we are
you know as governance going
trying to deal with this
uh yet i would i would like these things
flushed out
much earlier
including interest rate impacts
and project stage two for example of
streetscapes
even though it's been okay by council
it has not been allocated in the long
term plan for any funding
so i'm just weary that i don't want to
go through what we went through in june
this year
it's very uncomfortable and to me
i see it as unprofessional on from a
governance point of view
through yourself to you if i could just
get patricia to respond in relation to
where we currently are from the
financing side of it and what the
current model was
so at present um we're just preparing
the packs to go out to the teams to
start the budget process so we will
start the approach the budget process we
always budget for at least three years
going forward so they're having to do
some crystal ball gazing of themselves
about what things will look like at one
july next year
and our hope is that we when it the
november update to council we will also
be able to give you a headline about
where the numbers are looking at
okay so what would be the trigger
point for us to go
our long-term plan
is too ambitious we need to re-look at
that
seriously and and go
fair enough back then seemed plausible
but there's been changes
rather than plotting a dead horse when
do we actually go
we need to actually
have another go at this
for sure
you want to you want to go let's stress
in here
to long-term plan
an amendment to the long term plan one
year out from when we're going to be
redoing the long term plan
would be um not advisable
i think the bottom line the bottom line
is
is that you are now entering the process
we we have we have a number of things
that are going to come together
in this in this
quarter one and quarter two of this
financial trading quarter two which is
we're going to get our annual draft
annual results next month right well we
are we know it's coming up on the work
program
um uh
you're going to get you're going to
start getting your budget numbers coming
in you're getting the higher level
financial strategy challenges of
of uh contra the state of the contract
and market your contract rates your
interest rates debt levels
they're all starting to come together
now in this coming
quarter
so rather than saying that suddenly
gives rise to a change or not you need
that information don't you to be able to
credibly financially plan and make the
sorts of
assessments that you're calling for in i
think is the really the point that we're
making so the the critical thing is
michael and patricia and rhiannon that
started
and it's going to come together
somewhere in this quarter too correct
yes
yeah
right here that's that's where it's at
in
i wonder i've got darren and dean leslie
thanks jim look i think it's a little
rich to be
accusing staff of not informing us of
some of the potential um because when we
went through the long-term plan process
they were very clear
and pointing out to us that it was an
ambitious long-term plan particularly
since we were going into
some of the largest
annual budgets for capital expenditure
that we've done
the variations are significant there's
absolutely no question about that but
the
ongoing effects of the pandemic on the
construction industry and the supply for
the construction industry and the effect
on infrastructural work as well
is well documented
and
for at least the last four to five years
whilst the country has enjoyed very low
interest rate interest rates staff have
continuously warned us of the
chance for that to change
and that's generally as a result of
what's going on geopolitically
um and and the effects that that would
have
uh
that's being realized you cannot say
that it wasn't signaled
thank you darren leslie
thank you mr chair darren said it i'm
not going to repeat it right
thank you
this raises the really important point
you know i appreciate
the the the stuff that you raise this
raises the importance of us
um um keeping our focus in the right
area of the financial strategy
because actually that's what we're we're
we're talking about so that's good so i
i think i saw nobody first go then and
you've got after you sure i just want to
reinforce what rangy's been saying
um
and i'm only a first-term counselor so
i'm open to being wrong on this issue
but i don't see anything that prevents
an incoming council
to
pause any project they want to they'll
be held accountable with the community
for doing so
uh the long-term pain does not lock us
into a schedule that we subsequently
find is unsuitable
um so
for arguments say we could
pause or cancel stage two of
streetscapes we could pause the
investment in years two and three into
this building
and we could reschedule the time framing
of the museum and so on
there's nothing to prevent that we don't
have to wait to this to the middle year
of every trianium to review the
long-term plan i think councils have a
mandate given the volatility of what's
in front of us to do that
you know and i support his view that
we can't just
continue to go on the way we're going on
and then end up next year saying oh
sorry it's not four percent it's six and
a half or seven percent again because
that has a compounding impact that just
is a legacy for the future
so i think we we need to have a review
process which is not talking about which
projects or the nuts and bolts of what
the staff are doing their advice is
valuable but it's a matter that an
incoming council can
change the direction i guess of where
they want to go on some of these
projects
thank you novi in what i'll say
yeah like i'm not sure if i'm suffering
from my head injury or not because i
asked a simple question on tuesday and
and failed to receive
a relative simple answer and today i
asked a question on what would be the
trigger point
to
you know the threshold to re-look at the
long-term plan i thought that was a
reasonable question
and the fact to that the comment that
it's rich asking that question
i feel
from the chair of ppp is uh
either i don't understand why jim and i
didn't say that was rich asking the
question i said it was rich criticizing
staff can i can i just um suggest that
we stay on top of here please okay so
the issue the issue is and you know i've
tried to deal faithfully with your
question when does the trigger occur
and and that's why i tried to sum up by
saying the trigger occurs when we have
the information
right and it wasn't a criticism of staff
it was obviously there comes a point
where
combined factors out of our influence go
look what you did back then
in 2021
can no longer work
and and that is the timing of
that trigger
for us and governance to be able to
use
the tools
and decision-making processes that we
have available and i thought that's a
reasonable question but
next time i've got some more questions
here later on i want to review those
let's keep it at the principal level the
question that you've asked i think the
the critical answer is we have from
staff
the process
which unfortunately is the way in which
the council will have to work this one
through the critical thing is clearly
the information that will be coming
together within the next quarter which
is going to determine
um the nature of quite frankly the
probable recommendations you leave for a
new or incoming council
in terms of actually does that does a
trigger get
triggered or have to be pulled or
whatever is the right the right analogy
are there any other questions
that people would like to raise of
patricia particularly around the report
can we move to the recommendations
please
and um
that we received the report that's fine
secondly we note to the debt position
which is both at a gross level 100.8
million dollars and also the net debt
balance of 43.3 which of course is the
critical one from our
rating agency's perspective important
for us to note be we commenced i think
this resolution our last meeting in june
which is just recognizing that we are
monitoring
the fact that if in terms of our
treasury management limits
the uh the nature of our hedging
cover
that's converting debt from floating to
fixed rate is at this stage in breach of
our policy
as we anticipate in year
years two to four uh but we are agreeing
here
um uh not to take any action
because it's going to depend on i guess
a reassessment hello quarter two we're
talking it's going to become pretty
critical
about the level of debt we actually have
because the level of debt will determine
what what that what the extent of that
coverage is
um we note that the current interest
rate assumption for the current year
2223 is valid
so again we go back to the treasury
management report point it's going to
it's going to hit us we have to roll our
debt and we've seen the profile on that
and we also note the outstanding deal on
all types of content all types
sorry debt of all types
continues to reduce
that's a very fulsome set of
recommendations there are no no the page
i don't think there are okay can i i'll
move from the chair that we we adopt
these all as a suite of recommended
resolutions do i have a second to please
thank you darren appreciate that then
discussion on the motion
they are important motions we are
acknowledging a policy variation here i
just want to stress that there'd be no
no no debate i'll put the motions then
please all those in favor please say aye
all right those against it's carrie
thank you very much
right remove the next item
which is our policy program welcome back
brandon
a big list as we saw last time
um
thank you chair so um this report deals
with the policy program update the only
thing that i'll just really draw
attention to is
we have been focused obviously on the
priority areas of bylaws many of which
have been due for review or others which
have needed review because
of regulatory changes or changes in the
operating environment so we have had a
very full program so i'm really pleased
with the progress that we have made and
i just want to take this opportunity to
thank hayden who has done an awesome job
he is leaving us in a month so
um he can be very proud of the six
bylaws that we have
thank you progress
appreciate that randy and martin hayden
yes questions four for i ran out of the
stage
it seems like no oh sorry darren were
you well no no questions chair i guess
just to to recognize the significant
work we've done
relatively late in the term with having
to bring some of those policies and by
laws into alignment um
when i looked at the number that we'd be
adopting this month i thought well
that's going to be ambitious as we head
into an election but um it's it's gone
relatively smoothly uh so i'm happy to
move the two recommendations thank you
do i have a second
thank you ross just just before i put
the motion just just you raise a you
know you raise a good i mean a good
point about thinking hayden but if we're
losing hayden what's our capacity to
keep the initiative of cleaning these up
going going on
so luckily i have a new senior policy
advisor starting the day that hayden let
you said that is fortuitous but yes we
will need to
um
progress replacing the policy advisor
you can harden yourself well on good
planning that's good that's great to
hear that we can keep the initiative
going
okay we have a we have uh darren and
ross moving the motion that we received
the report and note the policy scheduled
um is there any discussion on the debate
sorry any discussion on the motions
i'll put the motion then please all
those in favor please say aye
those against it's carrie thank you
we can move then to the strategic
projects program
update
that would be great do i have a staff
member speaking to me on this one
michael are you going to do the honors
thank you cheers
i'll take the report as read
the
key things i will highlight in relation
to the report is we've got a number of
our projects that are in in flight at
the moment so we've got a lot of
contracts
out for tendering in relation to this or
in commitment from that perspective
just wanted to highlight that because it
does relate to
to close down any those projects we
would need to um
welcome welcome here just kill the
cavalry's come over there come over the
ridge mates
just to close out uh what i was saying
that would we would need to work through
those because we'll have contractual
commitments in relation to those
projects and flight projects i'll hand
over to lee
welcome lee morning just just just in
time it's superb timing so you can watch
the live stream if you're prepared to
speak to your report i'd appreciate that
please
yeah look um no no significant comments
to make them just uh open to ask
any questions right reflect the fact
that that again um um this is for risk
this this we're a risk committee
willingness from a high level from a
from a management and a control
perspective rather than the work that
might be done by other committees do i
have questions for lee or indeed michael
at this stage
right
got a couple um if it's okay kaylee the
thing i noticed big from from this
report is is obviously the last time we
saw was in june and so now we've gone
into the new year and so i'm looking at
the um
uh the fee table or the the schedule of
um
costs on page 120 obviously things have
been normalized so so things like the
museum decisions have been made at a
policy level by council
what was previously showing as a
as a
essentially non-budget amount now has
got itself and it's placed in position
brilliant okay that's good and i and i
think i've seen from elsewhere well in
fact from your comments
uh some action that is that is going
that leaves the cab store with an
outstanding 10 million dollar question
correct absolutely yeah yeah okay what
does it take to solve that element is
that going to be through the next annual
planning process or next lpp or
something i think for us it's about just
working through
the cost reports
working through
scope
and just aligning them yeah so you know
that 26 million is
um sort of a concept um
financial review that says if you're
going to do all this this is likely what
the costs are as a team now we've got to
work through and try and get back to our
budget and look at what those uh what
those scope changes would be so it's at
the moment it's really a bit of a
what we want to achieve what's the cost
impact
before we come back with some sort of
options report very similar to the
museum process in that in that sense
absolutely context for you we've already
been discussing um sort of tangentially
um
the uh the city streets project yep and
i don't want a direct question to ask
you a direct question around that what i
don't want to ask you is the the
important one because clearly you've
noted that it's red
um so it's got its challenges and i
think i've picked up enough from today
note that i understand some of those
what i'm interested though is process
in control which is that
you've said currently the delivery
method is not working
and a change in delivery mode is being
considered could you just expand on that
for me what does that mean yeah it's
like it's the contract form it's how
we've structured um the consultants in
you know what order whose leading design
who's leading you know different aspects
of the work
um how we actually do the work you know
methodology whether we do drainage first
and get that out of the way before we do
city streets
you know the streetscapes work
so i mean looking at methodologies of
really how we do this you know do we
close the streets you know entirely so
there's some practical
applications that we look at and then
obviously some contractual applications
is this contract form worked
um
you know how that how that is structured
really
i i take it from the the
panel staging of the streetscapes we
have no active contracts and plagues in
place for the next stage so we have this
chance or you're taking this chance to
review the methodology
so that when you then go to market
you've got the the better methodology in
place yeah i think it's definitely
looking at what's working well and
what's not working well in in stage one
you know cherry picking what the good
parts yes and really analyzing the stuff
that's not working so well for us great
great and second to be a long process to
to to arrive at a new methodology no no
i mean we've um we've carried out quite
a bit of work already to be honest with
you and we're continuing working you
know carrying out those workshops
um so yeah we're
i would say by the end of this year we'd
have a very very clear picture of the
best way to go about that brilliant well
your challenge is to make this this
document stay green as it looks like at
the moment which is always what most
documents look like at the start of a
financial year so yeah i'm pleased to
look at it with interest as things go on
[Laughter]
are there any other questions at the
stage philly yes i've got leslie then
then
thanks mr chair i'm just interested on
page 120 lee the um
housing innovation project
can you just expand a wee bit on
that i see the you've overcome some
challenges around space planning and
parking yeah so um that that project
started off as healthy homes where we
were doing some upgrades uh around that
i thought we'd completed we have
completed that the second part of that
is the developing um new units
so we're looking at a couple of sites on
one particular site that we've got we
call it site one and we had some issues
around trying to fit um the right number
of units on that we had some then we had
some parking compliance issues we're
trying to fit parking in and with and we
pretty much overcome that but a bit of
re-jigging uh where the units would sit
uh and i took a transport or traffic
review of that to uh
to get over that too
great that is indeed um groundbreaking
stuff yeah no it's yeah it's exciting
stuff thank you
thank you leslie uh in
right from a governor's point of view
regarding the cab project now
are we just currently looking um
the figures obviously we started 8.3 and
now there is talk of 26 but obviously
you've said
that scope needs to be adjusted but that
is purely to do with the re-permanent
refurbishment of this current building
the building we're in correct and no
work
has yet been undertaken
on what would be the tipping point
where
you would go
now to achieve what we want
we need to abandon this building and
look at something new and look at the
options around
uh the benefits that that may have
and all that you you completely jump to
a different line of track so when is
that going to happen or you know we're
near that yet
yeah we know any of that yet i think
stage one is about really understanding
exactly what we want and what we
actually what we've got and then what we
want and i think we're very close to
understand well we do know what we've
got um and now we're really trying to
align what we want to achieve
with either budget or be what what what
alternative option might look like
right when would you seek
uh feedback from governance on that
actual
expenditure and budgeting and the
options around
uh yeah i mean we had the museum options
we had
you know fixing up the old museum that
was one of the options and then we had
the other options of rebuilding you know
a couple of
options so
is it gonna go that way i think for us
um our milestone program i think it's a
april or may for bringing an options
report back to council right
okay
thanks cheer
do you have any other questions sorry
yes sorry uh nobby um just on the issue
of the housing innovation
so is this project um implemented by the
recent decisions that we made around the
5.7 million government funding
which we initially thought would go
towards a new museum but after
consultation with nana fenwa it was
decided that two of the five point seven
million would go to
um improvements in this sector is that
is that part of the thinking going
forward or is that yet to be decided on
three self chair i can cover that one
off um
both projects are separate from that
perspective it's an additional amount
this was the one where we
put forward to
improve our housing stock in relation to
the long-term plan
through the rental changes
thank you
for a very useful discussion appreciated
i don't know we just moved to the motion
unless there are i don't think there are
any other questions which is that we re
we received the report
i'll move that from the chair to have a
second to please
thank you in
the discussion on the motion i'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye all right those against us carrick
thank you lee appreciate your effort
being here it's great and michael for
your uh your short coverage
uh can we now move then please to
um the actual work program uh as we look
forward thank you michael
thank you through yourself chair i will
take the report as read it is a
program that is very much in line with
last year's program from that
perspective a few minor changes in
relation to some of the timing uh noting
that august is normally when we do our
annual plan program
sequencing and you'll see that in
in the
program report as it's laid out this
year i would note that we've got the
september and december 22
uh
calendar um or meeting schedules in
there that have got dates that have now
changed a little bit because we have
sequenced
reports to come forward into the august
meeting which would normally not be in
that meeting i've not reflected those
changes in in this
work plan because that this work program
is the approved work program
from last year and those two green
columns so the forward work program is
very much in line with ongoing work
program
thank you appreciate that there any
questions that people had to raise with
uh
uh
michael sorry
no there are nobody looks like you you
really are yeah i just i'm just going to
move the recommendations oh thank you
on the premise of my previous comments
that in december 2022 which is after the
current election
we will have confirmation of terms and
reference for for this committee i think
that's an important piece of work yeah
uh not be just on that i was reflecting
i have asked that we do a a short survey
and i think it's out isn't it um uh on
on this committee
and uh um i know i've
filled mine out i think i'm glad to say
i hopefully i don't want to encourage
those of you who have been sick well all
council should be circulated indeed
senior management because i think that's
a good set piece to then consider some
of the questions you're raising so i
look forward to that chance uh i guess
at the september meeting the other thing
just note about the september meeting is
that is that
um a central piece of that will be the
receipt of the draft
uh the draft annual report and a
consideration of what um
resolutions we could pass and leave for
the incoming council which is really
important given it's uh we know that our
our opinion won't and can't be signed
off until about the 20th of december
next year next year that's a 40 and
slippery
joke um so
uh um they are a couple of key things so
with that nobody's moved i have a second
to please thank you ian i'll put the
motion all those involved please say aye
those against us carried thank you very
much that michael and it's good to keep
a
a a record like this going of what we do
um
we are at the point now where uh
consideration of matters of virgin
business i've said nothing has been
raised with me so propose we move on
uh and as i think we probably do a break
i would just like to go uh um move this
motion so that melody can do the right
administrator stuff
could we look uh to move and i will move
from the chair
uh that we move into public excluded for
the reason for the items on a to j for
the reasons that are outlined did you
second that yeah thank you very much any
questions
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say i have another question those
against carrie thank you for keeping me
up to mark there